like the past several days the people of
China again woke up to news that the
coronavirus has claimed more lives and
more people have become infected living
with his family in Wuhan alie wari moved
to China
25 years ago we spoke to him on skype
are you worried even further down the
line that this this quarantine could
last a month six weeks so this is all
this concern is shared by people here in
Beijing I'm very worried about the
disease I always wash hands before and
after Meuse and every time I go out I
wear a mask
[ __ ] SARS time we didn't realize how
serious the situation was but we've
learned in doing much more actively now
the government is responding quickly and
we fully support them 17 years ago the
Chinese government was criticized for
acting too slowly when the SARS virus
killed nearly 800 people while most of
who Bay province the epicenter of the
corona virus is now under lockdown
there's concern about the people who
traveled before restrictions were put
into place this as there's growing
evidence that people might be carrying
the virus without showing symptoms
unwillingly passing it on to others the
DEET on Park here in central Beijing
would normally be teeming with people
out celebrating the first day of Lunar
New Year but like right across China the
festivities here have been canceled over
concern of spreading the virus
nationwide measures are being put into
place on airplanes trains and buses to
detect infected people the people of
Wuhan are being told that starting
Sunday no cars will be allowed on the
streets of the city center hundreds of
military medical personnel have been
sent to Wuhan to help with the growing
number of cases this is in addition to
the more than 1,000 civilian medical
staff who have already been sent in from
around China Wuhan hospitals are
overcrowded and some who have been
treating patients have been infected so
as the people of trying to have a muted
celebration it's still far from clear
what impact the Wuhan coronavirus will
have on the Chinese New Year ahead